FBI TEXT MESSAGES GO?
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS "THE ANGLE" ."
SEEING THE LOOKS ON SOME
DEMOCRATS FACES TODAY AFTER THE
GOVERNMENT WAS REOPENED IT WAS A
THOROUGHLY ENTERTAINING.
I WAS SMILING ALL DAY LONG.
SHE LOOKED LIKE SHE ATE
SOMETHING BAD IN A SENATE DINING
ROOM.
DISTURBING DURBIN LOOKED LIKE HE
SWALLOWED BOB CORKER.
LOOK AT HIM.
DONALD TRUMP IN THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP OUTSMARTED THEM
AGAIN.
AGAIN, IT'S A WILE E. COYOTE IN
ROAD RUNNER.
GOVERNMENT TO HELP ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WAS A WILDLY
UNPOPULAR, IT QUICKLY FELL
THROUGH.
EVEN BY FRIDAY, MORE UNDERSTOOD
THE TRUTH THAT THEY PUT THE
WOMEN IN OUR ARMS AND
FORCES.
THINK ABOUT THIS WAY, IMAGINE
BEING DEPLOYED IN AFGHANISTAN.
AND THEN YOU FIND OUT THAT THE
FOOLS ON THE HILL ARE MORE
WORRIED ABOUT ILLEGAL ALIENS
THAT ABOUT YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
THAT MUST FEEL REALLY GOOD.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARY
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUAR8
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARH
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUAR,
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARA
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARD
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARI
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUAR
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARO
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARH
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARN
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUAR
IMMIGRATION ISSUE UNTIL FEBRUARA
AND OPEN DEBATE ON IMMIGRATION,
INCLUDING A DACA FIX.
>> IT ENDS THE SHUTDOWN AND
RESTORES FULL FUNDING FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH
FEBRUARY THE EIGHTH.
IF AN AGREEMENT ISN'T REACHED BY
FEBRUARY THE EIGHTH, THE SENATE
WILL IMMEDIATELY PROCEED TO
CONSIDERATION OF LEGISLATION
DEALING WITH DACA.
>> Laura: BIG WIN, CHUCK.
"THE BOSTON GLOBE"'S ADVISOR SET
IT UP THIS WAY IN A TREE.
HE SAYS "DEMOCRATS HAVE MANAGED
TO COME TO THE PUBLICANS A MAN,
WE MORALIZE THEIR BASE, GIVE IT
DISENGAGE PRESIDENT A WIN,
AND A LOOK LIKE THEY HELD A
MEANINGLESS THREE-DAY
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
BETTER MYSELF.
EVEN BEFORE THE SHUTDOWN, THE
DEMOCRATS DREAM OF TAKING BACK
POWER IT WAS ALREADY FADING AWAY
BECAUSE OF THE ROARING STOCK
MARKETS AND THE STRENGTH OF THE
OVERALL ECONOMY.
MEDIA DO TO SAVE FACE?
>> IT'S A FOOL.
HE'S A JUST AN IDIOT.
LIKE HE'S A STUPID, OLD,
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT
INVOLVED THESE LAST FEW DAYS,
DESPITE THAT, THEY PREACH THIS
COMPROMISE.
>> THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE A
GOOD SENSE OF HIS GOVERNING
STYLE.
>> THIS IS THE SECOND TYPE IS TO
TAB HAS BASICALLY HAD TO TRICK
HIM INTO WATCHING TV AND
TWEETING INSTEAD OF BEING
HANDS-ON AFTER HE BUNGLED THIS
BY BEING HANDS-ON.
THEY ARE ALL BECOMING ONE PERSON
THAT WHEN I'M WATCHING THEM.
IT'S AMAZING HOW AMAZING SOME OF
THE SAME FANATICS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO RAM THROUGH AMNESTY
SINCE 2006.
THINK OF THEM.
GRAHAM, SCHUMER, AND GERMAN, ALL
CAREFUL IN THE COMING DAYS AND
WEEKS, NOT TO ALLOW THE FOX OUT
OF THE HENHOUSE OF THE DEBATE
MOVING FORWARD.
THINK ABOUT IT.
REPUBLICANS COULD NOT RID US OF
OBAMACARE LAST YEAR AFTER ALL
THOSE VOTES THEY HAD WHEN IT
DIDN'T MATTER.
BUT BY GOLLY, THEY ARE OBSESSED
WITH HELPING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
AS FOR DEMOCRATS, THEY JUST WANT
TO REPEAL AND REPLACE THOSE
BLUE-COLLAR AMERICANS WHO VOTED
FOR TRUMP WITH NEW IMMIGRANTS
WHO VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS GOT TO HOLD
FIRM, AND I THINK HE WILL.
NO CHAIN MIGRATION.
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THEN, I GUESS MAYBE DO THE
DACA THING.
YOU HAVE ALL THE LEVERAGE.
DON'T GIVE IT TO THE
POLITICIANS, MR. PRESIDENT, WHO
DON'T RESPECT YOU OR YOUR
SUPPORT.
BY THE WAY, THERE ARE SOME MORE
EVIDENCE OF THAT TRUMP IS MORE
IN THE MAINSTREAM ON IMMIGRATION
THAN LINDSEY OR CHUCK WILL EVER
BE.
CHECK OUT THIS NEW HARBERT
HARRIS POLL IT JUST CAME OUT
THAT TELLS US A REALLY GOOD
TALE.
65% VERSUS 35% SUPPORT A DACA
DEAL THE ENDS CHAIN MIGRATION,
ELIMINATES THE VISA LOTTERY, AND
SECURES A BORDER WITH A WALL.
81% WANT TO SEE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION LEVEL SLASHED.
YOU'VE HEARD IT, SLASHED.
79% THINK IMMIGRATION SHOULD BE
BASED ON SKILLS, RATHER THAN
FAMILY TIES, AND 60% BELIEVE
DREAMERS SHOULD NOT BE GIVEN
PREFERENCE TO BRING THE RELATIVE
TO THE UNITED STATES.
54% SUPPORT A PHYSICAL BARRIER
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
BORDERS.
WELL.
FAX NEVER GOT IN THE WAY OF
THESE OPEN BORDERS REPUBLICANS
BEFORE, BUT MAYBE WE CAN
HOPE THAT LINDSEY GRAHAM, JEFF
FLAKE AND THE OTHERS GET THE
MESSAGE.
MEANWHILE, WE STAY ON THE
CORRUPTION WATCH, AS WE LEARN
I WAS SHOCKED, SHOCKED, I TELL
YOU, TO HAVE FOUND OUT THAT THE
ONLY TEXT THE FBI FAILED TO
PRESERVE OR MESSAGES BETWEEN THE
ANTI-TRUMP FBI INVESTIGATOR
PETER STRAUCH AND HIS PARAMORE,
LISA PAGE.
REMEMBER, BOTH WORKED ON THE
IT WAS DURING THAT KEY PART
WHERE THE BOROUGH CLAIMS A
TECHNICAL PROBLEM WAS UPDATING
SOFTWARE THAT CAUSED A FAILURE
TO PRESERVE THESE MESSAGES.
ARE YOU SAYING, IS JUST LIKE
WHEN WE GET STUFF ON OUR
IPHONE AND WE WANT TO UPDATE,
WE ALWAYS SAY NO BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT THE PHONE TO SLOW
DOWN, IS THAT WHAT HAPPENED?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT'S THE FBI.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THEIR
EXPLANATION HERE.
I HAVE A THING I WANT TO TELL
YOU.
BY THE WAY, I LOVE MY PET ROCK
WHEN IT CAME OUT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
FRANKLY NOT NECESSARY FROM THE
FBI-RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
BUT NOW WE NEED AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW OF ALL OF THIS MONKEY
BUSINESS.
THERE'S TOO MUCH TO EXPLAIN
AWAY.
BY THE WAY, WE HAVE A LOT MORE
ON THAT COMING UP.
YOU DO NOT WANT TO MOVE BECAUSE
IT'S HOT TONIGHT.
INCLUDING THE GRADUAL PUSH TO
RELEASE THE HOUSE INTEL MEMO AND
THE FBI WARNED US OF WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT DAYS ON THE SHOW,
THERE'S NEW NEWS ON THAT.
THERE'S OTHER HUGE ECONOMIC NEWS
TODAY THAT I GOT TO GET TO THAT
WILL BE OVERLOOKED BY EVERYBODY
IN THE MEDIA, BUT NOT HERE.
ONCE AGAIN, WE WILL SHOW THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FULFILLING
THE PROMISES THAT HE MADE.
>> WE WILL STAND UP TO TRADE
CHEATING PEER CHEATERS, THAT'S
WHAT THEY ARE.
WE WILL STAND UP TO TRADE
CHEATING ANYWHERE AND EVERYWHERE
IT THREATENS THE AMERICAN JOBS.
>> Laura: THE U.S. TRADE REP'S
OFFICE JUST ANNOUNCED THAT IT
WILL GRANT RELEASE IN THE FORM
AS WELL AS A LARGE RESIDENTIAL
WASHING MACHINE.
THEY CITED SECTION 201 IN THE
TRADE ACT OF 1974 IT GIVES THE
PRESIDENT'S DISCRETIONARY
AUTHORITY TO GRANT RELEASE IF
THE INTERNATIONAL TRADE
COMMISSION FINDS THAT IMPORTS
HAVE BEEN A SUBSTANTIAL CAUSE OF
SERIOUS INJURY.
IT'S A REAL FINDING HERE.
THERE'S BEEN A PATTERN OF UNFAIR
THIS LAW PROVIDED ANY RELIEF
SINCE THE EARLY 2000s       200s
SINCE THE EARLY 2000s       200.
CAN YOU IMAGINE OBAMA EVER DOING
THIS?
OR HILLARY CLINTON?
HILLARY CLINTON NEVER WOULD'VE
DONE IT BECAUSE IT WAS HER
HUSBAND BACK IN 2000 THAT
THOUGHT IT WAS SUCH A GREAT IDEA
FOR CHINA TO JOIN THE WTC OH.
THAT WAS ONLY DIRECTED AT CHINA.
TRUMP'S TARIFFS APPLIED TO A
LARGE NUMBER OF COUNTRIES
ENGAGED IN THIS ABUSE.
NOW, OF COURSE TODAY'S TREAT
ENFORCEMENT ACTION -- IT'S ALL
WRONG, BUT IT'S SO PREDICTABLE.
AGAIN, THIS PATTERN OF UNFAIR
TRADE PRACTICES AND MAJOR
INDUSTRIES, THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING, IS OBSCENE.
OFTEN TIMES, EVEN WHEN WE GO TO
THE WTO OR WORLD TRADE COURT AND
RECTIFY THE DAMAGE, AND THAT
DAMAGE TO AMERICAN COUNTRY IS
ALREADY DONE BY THE TIME THEY
GET ANY RELIEF.
WELL, I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
ON TRADE, ON IMMIGRATION, SO
MANY ISSUES, THERE IS TRULY A
NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN.
AND WE ARE PUTTING AMERICAN
INDUSTRY FIRST, AMERICAN WORKERS